this is mr. Beck
Mysterio you can call me Quentin but you
handled yourself well out there today
soft you did with the tower I could use
someone like you on my world I'm sorry
you world mr. Beck is from Earth just
not ours there are multiple realities
Peter this is earth to mention six one
six I'm from Earth 833 we share
identical physical constants level four
symmetry
I'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse because I thought that was
just theoretical I mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
singularity see sorry
how's it going everybody it's Warren we
have so many different TV spots a couple
of different trailers a ton of leaks and
a few different clips of spider-man far
from home such as the one that I just
showed and it seems like we're getting a
lot from Marvel and Sony with all of
these different TV spots and the
trailers but all of the information that
we've gotten really makes us look at
only a few moments from the movie and
people are starting to pick up on this
it seems like everything that we get for
spider-man far from home whether it's a
TV spot or a trailer really just
involves Peter Parker mourning the death
of Tony Stark him wanting to tell MJ how
he feels and just be a normal teenager
and then you have the elementals and
Mysterio seemingly appearing to be a
hero that combined with the fact that
spider-man will get a few different
suits in the movie is really all that we
know about the film so a lot of people
are starting to ask what we're really
going to see in spider-man far from home
and a couple of different toilets
combined with some clips from the movie
are starting to give some people the
idea that we could possibly see a cameo
from a certain different spider-man from
a different universe and that different
spider-man is of course spider UK so
I'll break all that down in this video
I'm still doing my Marvel Legends series
collection when I hit 450,000
subscribers to enter all you have to do
is be subscribed to my channel like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so the thought that spider UK
could be in spider-man far from home I
think originated around January or
February it was right around the time
when we got the first teaser trailer for
Spider Man far from home
there was a toy leap that showed
spider-man in a red and blue costume
with white lines going around it much
like the spider UK outfit has the white
lines going around the British flag now
the figure did not have the British flag
on it but this was the first time that
people started to think that this could
be a hint towards spider-man UK
appearing in spider-man far from home
and then in the first official trailer
that we got for spider-man far from home
Mysterio literally mentions the
multiverse he says that he comes from a
different world and then we got an
exclusive clip the same one that I
showed in the very beginning of this
video of Mysterio literally
name-dropping universes he says that
spider-man's universe which is the main
MCU universe is earth-616 which is the
main universe from the comics and then
he says that he is from Earth 8:33 which
is literally the same universe that
spider UK comes from in the comics so
the universe that Mysterio comes from is
literally the same universe that spider
UK comes from so there is a direct
connection to spider UK here and now the
running question is will spider UK
appear in spider-man far from home many
fans actually thought they spotted him
in a few TV spots in all of the trailers
that we've seen Peter wears a lot of
different suits some people even think
that these are just different spider-man
from different universes and that one of
the suits that we see in the TV spots
and trailers that has a white trim on it
could be spider UK however a recent TV
spot that shows Peter Parker making a
new suit in Tony Stark's jet debunks
this theory in a way because after he
makes this suit we can see him jump out
of the plane and we can see the white
lines on the suit so this is just Peter
Parker in a brand new suit this could be
a little node to spider UK but I do
think there are some ways that he could
be in spider-man far from home or
mentioned there is a chance that he
could have followed Mysterio through
this dimensional rift that was caused by
the snap
we know that the elementals came from
the same universe as Mysterio which is
the same one that spider UK would be in
so if he watched the elementals and
Mysterio go through a dimensional rift
there's a chance that he could have
followed them so that's one way to do it
but I don't think they're going to do
that I don't think they'll take the
focus off our main spider-man Peter
Parker Mysterio and the elementals but
another way that he could make an
appearance is that we could see the
dimensional rift open up again at the
end of the movie and possibly see spider
UK on the other side Peter and or shield
figure out a way to open the dimensional
rift again to send the elementals back
to their universe and when the
dimensional rift opens up we see into
the other world and we see spider UK so
that's another way he could make an
appearance and the third way is he's
just in the movie and at some point in
time him
Peter Parker meet and realize there are
now two spider-man in the universe as
cool as this may be I definitely do not
think this is going to happen at least
in this movie who knows about spider-man
3 but in spider-man far from home I
think we're going to hear a mention of
spider UK I think Mysterio will mention
to Peter Parker while he's trying to
become buddies with him that there was a
spider-man in his universe and I think
he's going to make it seem like him in
the spider-man from the earth 8:33
universe we're best friends as well
which causes him to bond with the
current spider-man Peter Parker I
actually think that Mysterio could have
killed spider UK in his universe and
that we will eventually find that out in
spider-man 5 from home
he killed spider UK and everybody hated
him so when he got the chance to go to a
different world and be a hero he took it
and he took the elementals with him so
they could cause destruction and then he
could swoop in and save the day to make
himself look like a hero but fortunately
we only have about two and a half more
weeks until we officially find out what
is going on in spider-man far from home
but in the meantime let me know what you
think about spider UK making an
appearance in the movie and let me know
how you would like him to appear would
you like him to actually be in the movie
would you like some sort of a flashback
to mysterious earth or would you be okay
if they just mentioned him be sure to
leave a comment to let me know your
thoughts and again I'm doing a giveaway
at four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers I'll be picking three
winners to each choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain be sure to follow
me on social media for more giveaways
and as always thank you all so much for
watching will fall off
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your